[Musique]
quatre cent quarante sept hectares la
réserve de l'étang de saint paul est le
plus gros bassin versant de lille
autrefois grenier des premiers habitants
cet espace naturel sensible est alimenté
par 24 source
et cela au centre d'une des plus grosses
villes de la réunion impossible donc
pour la ministre de l'outre-mer de ne
pas passer et la première halte se fait
au milieu des vergers centenaire
l'occasion d'expliquer le contexte à la
ministre y est ici nous sommes sur une
zone de l'étang saint-paul propriété
pour une grande partie du conseil
départemental et nous conseil
départemental n'a confié donc la gestion
de cet espace à la mairie et aujourd'hui
nous avons le grand plaisir et l'honneur
d'accueillir donc là la ministre de
l'outre-mer sur cet espace naturel où
nous menons un travail remarquable en
partenariat bien sûr avec la régie et la
mairie pour préserver les espaces pour
préserver la faune la flore et puis bah
laisser aux générations futures
cet espace dans les meilleures
conditions possibles tout semble fier du
modèle go construit en ces lieux
l'exploitation agricole au milieu d'un
espace protégé semble illustrer le
message que voulait passer c'est qu'on a
le coeur et sait qu'il faut bosser pour
garder bat patrimoine et pouvoir en
tirer aussi un revenu bien sûr police et
la nature la nature ans tout simplement
ça la méthode biologique en fête avec
tout cet espace enherbé l'arrivée les
auxiliaires finalement ce sont les
auxiliaires qui font le travail suite de
la visite la zone humide mais là c'est
un peu plus compliqué pour y accéder
ça connaîtra en vase table ronde qui la
pierre les mille et les crevettes les
poissons blageon qui imagine un pot en
le coco imaginant qu'elles aient enfin
deux machines demain aspirine imagine
mon corps et âme l'hiver magie ni
crèvent la gueule on pouvait imaginer
demain à fait claire ainsi hors du temps
et pourtant si proche de la population
une zone tampon aux multiples usages qui
n'est pas toujours facile de concilier
chercher la fraîcheur ya mélange
innovation et est de tradition que
j'aurais tendance aurait tendance à dire
ici et puis ceux qui sont sceptiques il
faut leur montrer les résultats qu'on
vient de me montrer les canaux qui sont
plus larges
les espèces qui sont revenus que ce soit
les poissons les oiseaux ou certaines
espèces florales je crois que ça c'est
important aussi qu'on est moins
d'inondations c'est ça qu'il faut
montrer c'est le résultat
c'est je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a
toujours tendance à mettre d'avant en
avant ce qui est négatif pour une fois
mettant en avant ce qui est positif et
depuis que je suis ici depuis trois
jours de la positivité j'en ai trouvé
une nouvelle histoire de l'homme et de
la nature pour rêver d'un avenir en
équilibre
[Musique]